create something that you love I think
one of the hardest things that
entrepreneurs have to figure out when
they're creating their products or
services is that intersection of
creating something that they really love
and also creating something that other
people will love and listen to the
feedback from the market but also not
just blindly accepting it and also
created something that you absolutely
love and you genuinely believe in I
think too many entrepreneurs just chase
opportunity they're just listening to
what people are saying like oh you
should do this or you know they pick up
the entrepreneur magazine top hottest
jobs top 100 hottest businesses to start
and then go in there because they see an
opportunity but because they don't love
it because they're not passionate about
it then it never takes off it never goes
anywhere and so I look at this YouTube
channel as an example right you look at
the ants presta series a top 10 series
they're all requests like you guys are
asking me to do the next person and then
I always contribute what I came and I
pick the messages that I like it's a
combination of what you like and what I
like and I'm proud of every video that I
make I will not release videos on this
channel that I I don't love and I've
told my team we've held back some videos
we haven't launched on certain days even
though we have a schedule unless I love
the video that's going up and so
striking that balance is super super
important as an entrepreneur how r bring
this to the books is the book update
video last week I was talking about test
test test we're testing her subtitles my
publisher didn't like my initial
subtitle for the book and suggested a
few alternatives that I didn't like so I
said you know what we're going to test
it and I sent out six subtitles to my 30
people who wrote read the first draft of
my book I had my initial subtitle I had
a new alternative that i wrote i had a
subtitle from my editor i sorry for my
publisher one from my agent and two from
my team people who were helping me and
create the book the number one title
that came back so far is the alternative
version that i wrote the number two
title that came back so far was the
original title that i wrote and then the
other ones are ones that they wrote now
that's what to say like I know
everything and I'm the best and you know
you're
bastian you have to you know just only
listen to yourself not less in the
market the reason why I wanted to test
it was to get feedback from the market
that see what people thought because I
would need to combine what I love plus
what the market wants and that's what's
going to create ideally the best
subtitle the best title the best
products the dress service now I can't
lie that I'm happy that my two titles
are number one and two I didn't tell
people when i sent it out you know who
picked what title but when I looked at
my title I thought you know I want to
create something that that I'm really
proud of I want to create something that
if I picked up then I would want to read
it you know I didn't just mail it in or
didn't just delegate and say hey you
five people come up with a title I
wanted it to be something that I
genuinely loved of all of them I love my
alternative version the best and that's
what's leading right now it'll be pretty
embarrassing it all turns around and
that doesn't win but it's pretty far
ahead so I'm pretty solid in that
recommendation so I think just combining
those things right making sure that you
love the final product you not you're
not shipping something out you're not
creating the video you're not creating
the service you're not create a product
is below your standards that is below
you loving you say no to opportunities
that come in because you can't service
them well enough or you're not
passionate about it but at the same time
listening to what people are saying and
trying to service them and try to help
them when you can embrace that the genes
of that and then you have the roots of a
really successful business let's get to
your questions first up RSW 24 from
twitter i haven't a quick question about
publishing ebooks i'm looking to get
into the publishing business soon and it
will have a three thousand dollar budget
to work with I wanted to get some
pointers and advice for you on where and
how I should spend the money that's an
interesting question and you know I hate
spending money again till I'm making
money I would probably release some mini
ebooks first start making some money
from that and then pour that into new
ebooks to continue to kind of feed the
beast and feed the machine instead of
dropping 3k out of my wallet to start to
do it I think it depends on what your
skill sets are like going with this plan
of spending three thousand one of the
things that I found really helpful is
having a team to help me create my book
so you might need something to help you
do the background research for the book
you might need somebody to do Trin's
grabbing of interviews for your book you
might need somebody to help you edit it
and put it together depending on your
skills like if you're really if you love
you know how you write your really
strong writer you don't need any editing
which is really rare but maybe you're
that person then you don't need to spend
on an editor you know if you're not then
you should have somebody look it over
and give you some feedback I think the
most important thing you can do is
create a product that people will love
create a product that people will want
to talk about create a product that
people want to share if I had three
thousand dollars i would invest it into
the product if i look at where i spent
money on my book I went to travel to go
talk to people to interview for the book
that was money that I spent out of the
advance to go meet people because I
cared about the quality of the
information going in I hired somebody to
help me edit the book and sit in with me
on all the interviews and transcribed
the interviews and make sense of you
know a four our five hour interview and
take you like condensed that down into
you know a few pages worth of content
that's where I've spent the money on the
book and I think it's the highest
leverage is you can spend money on
marketing but if the book itself is not
fantastic it's not gonna help you on the
marketing side I would look at using
influencers more than any kind of
advertising program I try to get into
the media I tried to get in front of
influencers but doesn't have to cost you
anything like if you have a message that
is valuable that means something that
makes people excited then they'll be
interested enough to just look at it and
if I had three thousand dollars I've
invested into the product itself to make
it awesome next up relaxing sleep
station love the channel your visions
and goals Thank You relaxing sleep
station what advice would you offer to
someone with a chronic illness that can
limit their productive time to as little
as an hour a day I've started a
bootstrap business with a friend who
shares my goals of the business and what
we're trying to achieve I see out so she
has a major factor in the future but to
begin with that will be very difficult
what suggestions would you make as far
as how i can continue to be productive
entrepreneur where i can be so
significantly limited by the time i have
available to be productive great
question and not to diminish the
importance of the question but you know
we're all limited we all have these
things that hold us back we never feel
like it's the right time to launch a
business oh I'm married it can't afford
to do this all right you know I'm living
on my own and I can't afford do this or
I have kids now I can't
to do this is to risk it over enough
time I'm pulled in a million different
directions or someone in my family is
sick or you know I'm sick or there's all
these reasons right there's always
reasons for how you can't be successful
start focusing on the ones that you can
be successful start focusing on your
time not being the limiting factor but
you know when I have my one hour this is
how I'm going to spend it this is how
I'm going to be productive I can still
be successful and productive in the time
that I have and focus on the
opportunities and not the limitations
because there's going to be infinite
number of limitations that hold you back
where the successful entrepreneurs are
the ones who do what they can with what
they have if I had an hour a day I would
one make sure that i'm using an hour a
day every single day too many
entrepreneurs you know mail it in it's
like oh you know it's Saturday I don't
need to work on this or you know it's
such a nice day outside i'm gonna go for
a walk on my one hour or you know the
Blue Jays are in the playoffs I'm gonna
go watch that game or I really want to
see the new League of Legends patch that
came out so I'm going to play that game
you need to spend an hour every day on
your business if you spend an hour every
single day on your business with all of
the life issues that you have going on
you would be ahead of a lot of people
I'm being honest a lot of people will
work you know a full day and then not
work for a while or move on and test
different side projects and just give up
on their idea so it's being consistent
with that time every single every single
day then the next step I'd be looking at
is how can i make sure that the time
that i'm spending is of the highest
value because when you start a business
you're everything from the CEO to the
janitor and you want to spend as much
time I kind of CEO as possible thinking
about what's the highest leverage that I
bring I used to walk down the office
every morning think what is the most
valuable thing I can do in my business
today and try to do that first and yes
sir things that have to get done in the
company and ideally you know a later
time you can outsource some not feasible
to start when you don't have a budget
but making sure that you are spending
CEO time consistently that you're
spending time on things that you can
potentially be one of the best in the
world at because that's what's going to
help drive your business far forward not
doing the little tasks that you are not
fantastic at that really should be the
responsibility of other people or maybe
you don't do at all at the start so
consistency using that time
day to seeing it not as a limitation but
an opportunity and then three focusing
that time to do high value high leverage
tasks for your business LML beauty
rights in this might sound stupid but I
don't know what his book is about I
haven't seen the reset of other episodes
I haven't talked about the book is about
yet I've kind of alluded to it a few
times I'm still waiting on kind of the
go-ahead from the publisher once I get
into marketing mode we're going to focus
on that we're close I promise you I'm so
excited to be able to eventually talk
about this the final copy is with the
the publisher being edited we're going
back and forth gotta figure permissions
a bunch of things once that's done I can
be in marketing mode I can talk as much
as I want about it I hope and so as soon
as it happens you guys will be the first
to know I promise thank you for the
question the love the curiosity it's
coming I promise I know it's a long wait
but it's coming Simeon great video as
always I really enjoy watching you
thanks man you're such an inspiring
person I've searched for a while but I
couldn't find your email or any contacts
is there a way to get in touch with you
personally thank you once again for the
great work you do you just did man next
time this is that this is a super
important super important lesson the
next time you want to get in front of
somebody make sure you have a message
that they can respond to you just
reached me I'm responding to you but I
don't know what you need help with you
give me zero context and so I can't help
you right now where other people i'm
answering their questions and so when
you are reaching out and trying to get
help and trying to you know introduce
yourself to somebody make sure you give
them some contact so they can actually
give you some advice Alice Hardy what do
you think of multi-level marketing or
network marketing I'll it's not really a
topic for this book but I've talked
about it also a few times on my channel
it's just a business model and there's
nothing inherently wrong with the
business model I think a reason why a
lot of people look down on it is people
don't get the results that they're
looking for and by the way welcome to
irv entrepreneurship most people who
started a business don't have end up
being successful either I think people
pitch it too much as a money-making
opportunity and anytime you here just to
get rich quick scheme you need to run
the other way I think too many times
people are promoting products that
they're that they don't use themselves
that they have no story attached to that
they're just trying to go out and
promote and you cannot effectively sell
a product that you do
believe in if you are not willing to
recommend the product or service that
you're selling to your mother and you're
not willing to use it yourself and tell
your personal story you're not deeply
and emotionally attached to what you're
creating then move on to something else
so there's nothing inherently wrong with
network marketing multi-level marketing
is just that a lot of the people who
jump into it do it for the wrong reasons
if you look the ones who are the most
successful they're the ones who do have
that storytelling attached to it they do
have the deep emotional connection to
the product or services that they're
creating so it's just a business model
and there's nothing inherently wrong
with any business model it's much more
about the emotional connection you have
to what you're selling Lewis in my
opinion the best legit motivation
entrepreneurship channel Congrats all
the belief team from Portugal I
appreciate that Lewis much love from
Canada Paul Chan great work and we'll
have 50 plus interest in sections will
buy this book when it comes out thanks I
appreciate that Paul I'll let you know
when pre-orders come out we're looking
at december six release date but i don't
know exactly when pre-orders will open
up ricardo hey Evan will the book be
available in audio yes I now set a
number of episodes ago we got to prove
to have an audio version and a deluxe
ebook version which is not standard for
first-time author so I'm super excited
about that and as I also mentioned I'm
going to be fighting hard to be the one
who reads it because I don't think
anybody could read it like I could read
it because it's my words and I feel like
you should have that same attachment to
your product or service like nobody
could do it you know if you wrote a book
like you want to be the one to read it I
don't see why any I don't see why the
publisher would not want to have me read
it I feel like a lot of authors just
mail it in and they don't want to put
the time and effort into making a really
good audio version so yes is going to be
one it's going to be me I'm going to
fight tooth and nail to make it happen
and appreciate the questions so thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I love to know what you think
about the topic of making sure that you
love the product that you're creating
also you have a question about my book
or the book writing process that I can
help answer for you in the future video
leave it in the comments below and I'll
make sure to answer you thank you guys
so much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you see